vous aimez quoi chez clara sheller vaut
son impulsion et ce que j'aime chez ce
personnage c'est que ces défauts sont
mis longtemps avant que sécurité merci
le bourhis a propos je
n'aime pas cette série je n'aime pas
cette série
qu'est ce qui vous énerve chez elles
sont
son égoïsme oui mais pas comme ça à foot
bien sûr est ce que vous attendez le
prince charmant et tu ta vie privée
non je crois pas pourquoi parce que il a
plus les allures d'un prince charmant
c'est juste un monde d'hommes ah oui
aujourd'hui ça n'existe plus le prince
charmant non mais c'est une image qui
évolue c'est l'image qu'on a quand on
est enfant c'est on est bercés par ses
comptes là et puis cette image évoluent
et pluvieux grand blond sur son cheval
blanc avec une rose entre les dents quoi
sa bataille les magasiniers chez
champions il travaille comme tout le
monde c'est ça le point charland est ce
que vous croyez être une princesse
charmante vos je sais pas
oui tu trouve toi un arbre ou un
fermente charmante on va avoir affaire à
une interview pour plaire
[Musique]
on va voir si nous y avait tout pour
plaire voilà vous avez de gros seins bof
baril son plus petit qu'avant non
oui se rétracte
qu'est ce qui s'est passé mais fallait
choisir gros qu'hugo je suis s'est passé
j'ai préféré perdre un peu savent en
même temps ça va bien sûr ça va ils sont
plus petit qu'avant tu veux rester
dedans quéré
est ce que vous appelez votre mère au
maximum une fois par mois
owen on attendait c'est aussi une
question de
droit se faisait tout pour plaire à où
j'ai pas en fait
vous avez tués combien votre maman mais
maintenant on s'appelle souvent trop
souvent n'ont pas trouvé leur nom mais
suffisamment suffisamment est-ce que
vous passez moins de dix minutes pour
vous préparer le matin
douche comprise
c'est chirac
l'ampli ce
fait bien manger
je suis fier c'est quoi votre spécialité
une petite tartine de pain et beurre
est tombé à ne
faut pas y aller pour bouffer un vous
faites attention quand on vous prête une
voiture j'ai pas mon permis
vous vous taisez quand les hommes par la
table un certain
taton permis de parler à
nouveau ce que les jeunes d'aujourd'hui
ça parle quand les hommes par la
rencontre sans exception tu vois toi
t'es pas droit de parler à table
ça va partir
est-ce que vous avez expliqué le hors
jeu est hors jeu ouais
je pourrais le faire vous savez ce que
c'est un je crois que c'est quand
l'attaquant
il rentre dans la danse comment
s'appelle le tri-nations ces réparations
mans avant le mec qui va buter
et
puis d'aujourd'hui m6 a rien compris
quand même elle a essayé et laurent est
ce que vous gagnez bien votre vie
je commence vous aimez quand vous fasse
des cadeaux bien juste un bisou
j'aime bien les bisous et les cadeaux
est ce que vous laissez votre mec
regarder le foot à la télé ouais ouais
ouais tout pour plaire à maaf vous en
foutez si votre mec vous emmènera dans
des week-ends amour tout ça
non je m'en fous pas mal s'en fout non
fait le ménage
ah ouais mais ça m'apaise oui non mais
c'est pas le ménage fait plein de petits
rangements tout le temps au même endroit
rien quoi qu'est-ce
que vous séparer le blanc est la couleur
pour la machine
pardon à 40° spock et voilà les lieux
selon jeremy parce que moi je fais
renoir la ola la tétée défroqué dans la
france
pour les vêtements noirs vous et vous
utilisez les six spéciales mais l'ami
non pas du tout a pas du tout alors il
passe complètement estime serait foutu
bah oui voyez on pourrait s que vous
oubliez de mettre les sous vêtements
parfois non ça serait pas un oubli non
ça vous arrive ne s'est pas un oubli
j'ai répondu à votre question c'est des
jours il ya du vent
est-ce que vous coucher le premier soir
eux
ça peut arriver oui lendemain matin ça
compte pas vraiment
vous n'avez rien contre le sexe sans
amour en vous ça peut arriver
donc des points là vous avez envie de
faire l'amour des fois trois fois par
jour
oui
des fois le jeudi même si ça passe ça
si votre mec nous tromper ce que vous
lui proposez de vous rejoindre avec sa
maîtresse qu'ils habitent près pourquoi
pas
non non pas du tout est ce que vous avez
envie de vous faire échanger dans un
club échangiste contre quoi tranquille
note ça
donne ça va donner cependant pas de
rester privé ce que tu viens de faire je
suis
pas loin
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de in
a l'habitude abonnez vous mettez un peu
de bleu